d'accord, vous effleurez d'abord cet interrupteur,
puis cet interrupteur qui s'active, puis vous
appuyez sur ce bouton, ce qui vous donnera
cinq minutes pour sortir de là maintenant,
quoi que vous fassiez, n'appuyez pas sur ce bouton
car cela déclenchera la bombe
immédiatement et nous allons  soyez tous morts maintenant
répétez ce que je viens de dire je vais bien
uh-huh je vais bien c'est bon ok
non maintenant c'est le bouton qui tuera
tout le monde réessayez je vais bien je vais bien
uh-huh oh c'est exactement là  tu viens de
dire comment est-ce même possible lequel
est le mais tu es censé
insister dessus  le bouton de la mort
vous